okay good morning everybody this is the
interim study committee on house bill
1229 we have been referring to it as the
school meals bills
subcommittee I'm representative Sue
Mullen from Bedford the chair of the
committee and with me at present our
representative Alicia Lucas
Representative Steve Woodcock and
representative Arthur Ellison good
morning everybody
you have in front of you two documents
this morning that I want to draw your
attention to
um I I think we'll actually put the
the cart before the horse and look at
the committee report first because I
think that the robust discussion that
might take place on the subsequent
information that we had to our vote last
time we met uh
is something that we're going to want to
have but I'm not sure that we will have
adequate time to do both so
okay so you have all seen the uh
committee report I will just review it
for uh the Publix consumption it says
the interim study committee on house
bill 1229 voted 5-0 on October 6 not to
recommend further legislation pertaining
to the bill as written
the committee heard comments from
professional organizations such as the
New Hampshire hunger project the
American Heart Association and the
Department of Education and was privy to
considerable research conducted by
Jennifer fore assistant director of
House communications Services regarding
actions taken by states with similar
demographics towards ending student
hunger consequently we do not feel any
additional study is warranted I'll
remind you that house bill 1229 was the
stud at the interim study to determine
if we needed a study of the study of the
study
so uh we're we're back to Ground Zero
again
however the committee does recognize
that addressing student hunger is both
important and necessary
future legislation regarding how to
increase the participation of eligible
families funding mechanisms accessing
maximum federal dollars available and
implementing measures already instituted
by states with similar demographics such
as Maine Vermont New Mexico Delaware and
West Virginia should be considered
I uh intend upon entering this report on
behalf of the committee uh if anybody
has any objections speak them now or
forever hold your peace
representative woodcock
thank you madam chair good morning
um I don't have a question as regarding
the report I support the work you've
done uh it's been terrific and you've
done a super job in this committee as
well as the support from uh Kelly and
doe uh and Jennifer my my question is
just my understanding uh in the second
paragraph when you're talking about the
the things that percolated out of the
dialogue over the multiple meetings you
had so
all of those issues then would be the
responsibility of the next legislature
for people to bring in legislation that
may be appropriate to those particular
issues but the report that we're
submitting uh now that we were on the
last minute is no for any more study but
rather now it's up to the independent
legislators to take actions that correct
that is correct okay thank you very much
you're welcome appreciate it
additional comments
all right oh representative fleckis
well done Sue thank you very much I
appreciate your support
um all right so without any objection
then I will submit this report on behalf
of the committee
to the second piece of information that
you have in uh in front of us our
friends at the doe Kelly Rambo being in
the audience this morning uh
followed through on the request that was
made at the last meeting to look at what
the total cost to the state of New
Hampshire would be
if we fed every school-aged child every
meal and did not require eligibility
into the program so that's breakfast and
lunch for everybody
you have those figures in front of you
um with eligibility numbers as well
the bottom line here is that the total
cost to the state with no eligibility
requirements so to feed everyone would
be 111 million two hundred and fifty
thousand nine hundred and eighteen
dollars and 80 cents now I don't know
about you but I'm curious about those 80
cents I want I want to know where they
came from and how Kelly uh was able to
come up with that exact figure
if in fact we looked at
just eligible
participants so we're talking about kids
who are qua who qualify for free and
reduce free or reduced lunch then the
cost to the state would be 654
822 dollars
so everybody's follow along with that
so this you know this is obviously this
is a data point that is necessary in the
discussion of School meals uh and in to
representative woodcock's point
future legislation legislation which
would be legislation that would be
written and submitted in the fall of
2022 after we know who's been elected
um
will have access to these numbers now in
a way that they didn't meaningfully
before now
and I certainly thank
the doe for the work that went into it
and uh I will take any questions or as I
mentioned we have Kelly Rambo from the
doe with us this morning if anybody
would like to hear from her just let me
know
representative Woodcock yeah thank you
madam chair you may be able to answer
this or Mr Rambo uh if you can't but I'd
be surprised if you couldn't uh
if the proposal in the future was to
provide uh lunches and breakfast for all
student youngsters in the school uh how
would we go about then filing for
eligibility for federal reimbursement
for if we didn't uh separate
it's a great question I I I
representative Woodcock despite your
vote of confidence do not have the
answer to that so I'm going to direct it
to Kelly Rambo who has already taken a
seat at the table
thank you
good morning Kelly Rambo from the
Department of Education thank you for
your question
um the long of the short answer is we
can't so we need
um and just to clarify the the number
that is in front of you I did take the
free and reduced eligibility from 2122
to apply to those numbers so there is
some free and reduced in there although
the data is due to covid
um not as
um accurate as it as it could be so we
could do it for this year once we have
that data but we need a
a point to start with to be able to say
we have this many free students we have
this many reduced students we have this
many paid students and that's going to
be the determinator for our federal
reimbursement and we have to identify
those students based off of the um
direct certification that we currently
have or the free and reduced
applications process that we currently
have as well
representative Woodcock thank you
material just then so
youngsters or families of youngsters
that are uh eligible for either free or
free reduced lines but still if this if
we went through that package that way we
still have to uh do some type of
paperwork and apply so the state could
get the federal funding to supplement
the state costs that's correct okay
thank you very much thank you madam
chair
other questions by members of the
committee
yeah
well but representative luno we would
welcome a question thank you very much
Madam chair
um and and thanks for taking my question
I'm not on this um this uh uh interim
study subcommittee but um I heard you
mentioned direct certification and that
was a tool that the the New Hampshire Ed
has and I was wondering
um I I what you meant by that
sure so that's the students that are
directly certified by DHHS snap TANF
along those lines that's that's a list
that's given to us from from Department
of Health and Human Services
foreign
Medicaid eligible students that does not
include Medicaid thank you so that was
the that's the direct certification that
we do not have that is correct thanks
other questions or comments for uh
Ms Rambo
okay thank you Kelly
all right unless the committee uh wants
discussion amongst themselves and
representative Woodcock I'm looking
towards you because I know that uh these
numbers were requested by you earlier on
I have no further discussion I think
that the data she provided I appreciate
the fact she went back and we did
mid-current data which I know took a lot
of time and I I do wonder where that 80
cents come from it came from as well
um I noticed she didn't get to that 80
cents but
um I I would hope that the state uh
Regals the fact that they didn't provide
the opportunity for the Medicare
reimbursement which they could have that
slipped out of our hands
um beyond that I'm hoping that next year
that we'll be able to recognize the need
of feeding every single youngster in our
schools and uh anecdotally and as I
think I said last time speaking with
some of the elementary school now the
Middle School folks the number of middle
class kids who would be on that border
uh has increased and those kids today
again coming to school hungry uh and are
hungry because of the fact that parents
don't have enough money based on the way
the living circumstances particularly
Apple we are in the tourist area of
Northern New Hampshire so I think it's
our responsibility if we everyone around
this table who's been involved in
education knows the importance of the
nutritional development of the brand the
youngster and we can go right back to
Maslow's theory if you don't have a
place to live and you're hungry you're
not going to learn now this is ancient
so I think it's a time that we do that
and I hope uh look forward to find
co-sponsors that will support that uh
next year so we can move that forward
assuming we're re-elected thank you
other comments or questions
representative Lucas
that did bring up a question and that's
where is the state going to come up with
a hundred and eleven million dollars
to pay for feeding every child breakfast
and lunch if I may respond I'm not sure
certainly well we're looking at
multi-millions of dollars for school
lunch we give it for I mean school aid
we're giving away right now under the
trust fund uh to Senate we keep kids
home and send them to religious schools
and we cut a hundred million dollars a
hundred million dollars we cut out a
financial out of the trust fund to give
it back to who
so that that hundred million we cut out
is a wonderful tax piece out of trust
fund to start the year could pay for
every youngster in this school district
every school district e so the money's
there representative this is the fact
that we have to determine how we want to
prioritize fee kids I think that's the
top of the list
representative luno thank you very much
Madam Sharon don't don't forget about
the uh the 10 million dollars that the
state is giving to wealthy investors who
lost money in a get rich quick scheme
um it's the only state in the country
it's ever bailed out investors and uh
and uh you know hopefully we won't be
doing that again and that's 10 million
dollars that could go towards I think a
program with much higher should have
higher priority than that
representative Hall I want to call you
in as present
I introduced everyone prior to and said
that I couldn't wait for you to come
through the door so that I could
introduce you as you arrived this
morning so thank you for coming in early
uh and uh right and representative Ford
is here as well uh barring any other
questions or comments I'm going to ask
for a motion to adjourn the meeting
I moved to adjourn the meeting and
discontinue the subcommittee after the
submission report
I have a motion do I have a second
all right I have a second from
representative leckis thank you very
much I appreciate your heartfelt
participation uh on the topic of feeding
hungry kids and I look forward to seeing
what comes out of our work thank you
sorry
okay I'd like to go ahead and uh open up
this meeting uh for the interim study
bills which we have this is the
education committee on the third floor
and we have 15 bills today which we're
going to be looking at and
I'm going to call for a five minute
caucus right from the beginning here so
the individual saw you know positions
can be be communicated
um so at this point in time we'll go
into about a five minute caucus and then
come back and start trying to get
through these bills today these are
interim study bills as everybody needs
to know the the way you go on the
inter-study bill is you either recommend
it go forward or it's not recommended
for future legislation there's two
options and you can put some you know
little bullets associated with each one
of those positions so but in large part
we have two options which we can go in
these things
so let's take this uh this brief caucus
here and
let's be back by
by quarter of
one one minute yeah one minute
foreign
okay we'd like to go ahead and start
walking down through the
um uh interim study bills here and I'd
like to do it in um we may jump around a
little bit due to uh we do have one
member here that has to be out by 11 30.
and um so we may jump around a little
bit that's representative Nelson
um
and I'd like to also thank represent
Nelson for serving on the education
committee this is your you're getting
out after this this session here so and
I understood Mary was getting up but
she's not getting out I've gotten for a
punishment representative Heath
um
yeah and I've enjoyed having
representative Heath on the commission
which we've dealt with the
infrastructure Public School monies
which are available and we did make some
healthy gains on that and those monies
of course as soon as they are through
governor and Council will be available
to the schools to help with some of the
security access issues we have out
going on
well that's right Sue yeah you're headed
for the
you graduated
it has been one of the greatest honors
of my life to serve the people of
Bedford and the state of New Hampshire
and I thank you all for your hospitality
and uh
best of luck to everybody yeah and we've
enjoyed you working on so many of the
issues like special education you were
sent in that committee and we hammered
that out the pre the one we're going to
hear today uh on on meals so thank you
very much so uh
you will be missed
yeah
11 37 relative to the duty of school
boards to provide education I recognize
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman
the subcommittee met and the
recommendation was that it uh not be
recommended for future legislation
sorry
um we're 11 37 our subcommittee uh
decided that it not be recommended for
future legislation
is there a second in that motion I'll
second that represent Hopson makes the
motion the second uh not moving this uh
legislation forward
um is there any discussion on it
if I might just offer a couple of things
we uh there were a wide variety of uh
duties listed in the legislation
um we had uh discussion going through uh
most all of them individually there were
a few that um I think most of the
subcommittee agreed
should be looked at for future
legislation including
um uh the possibility of a survey of
parents
um at the end of the year and also a
link on District websites to the vast
amount of data that the Department of
Education is making available on their
um I platform
but as a whole we recommended 1137 not
go forward
further discussion
not seeing any requests further
discussion uh representative moffatus
our clerk for today he's filling in for
representative Litchfield
it's yours
name is sharing the motion of not
recommended for HB 1137
uh representative cordelli
do I met you
the motion is not recommended
the
minority party first no no no no no no
oh see I'm really losing it
better start drinking more coffee here
sock said not to the same answer yes I
think so too go ahead
excuse me okay and the recommendation of
not recommended uh on HB 1137 uh
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes
president of Boom
representative leikis yes
representative moffatt says yes to the
motion representative Hobson yes
representative Ford yes representative
Sardi yes representative Nelson
representative Miler yes
representative luno yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison
representative Muller yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath
representative Hall
representative Ladd yes
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 to
zero
so we have a vote 19-0 on interim
studies we there is no consent calendar
it's just all the reports go together
underneath education
so going on to the next bill HB 1141
relative to special education services
for children in Charter Public Schools
representative Cordelia
recognize for a motion
uh yes uh I would move
not recommended for future legislation
is there a second
represent boom seconds the motion
representative cordelli do you care to
speak to your motion uh just that there
were um uh several uh different things
included in this bill uh some of which
have already been addressed
um some other Provisions might be
addressed in the future but um as uh as
a bill uh my recommendation would be not
recommended for future legislation
further discussion
not seeing any folks requesting any
discussion representative moffatt
on the motion to not recommend HB 1141
representative cordelli
yes
representative Hill
representative boehm yes
representative blackis yes
representative Moffett says OCS
representative Hobson
yes representative Ford yes
representative sodium yes
yes representative Nelson
representative Miler yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes yes
representative Ellison
representative Mullen yes representative
woodcock
representative Heath
representative Hall yes 19-0
representative lags yes uh
representative Vlad says yes making it
19-0
12 29 we did have a subcommittee uh and
the chair of that subcommittee is
representative Mullen represent Mullen
do you have a report
I do do you have a motion uh I do I the
subcommittee and myself move that we not
recommend future legislation based on
House Bill 1229
okay
um is there any discussion on that as a
subcommittee or do we can just go right
into the other and take make take a
motion from you uh I'll I'll just speak
to the bill and just for clarity's sake
uh chairman Ladd
we did not recommend future action on
the bill because the bill itself was to
establish a study committee the
committee studied as you well know uh we
we studied a lot from June until this
morning so the recommendation of moving
forward with the study committee is is
it's not recommended however
we had fruitful
eye-opening conversations about student
hunger in New Hampshire throughout the
process and the report does indicate
that there are a variety of topics that
should be considered for future
legislation uh primarily around
eligibility Federal funding how to
access federal dollars that kind of
thing so we we support
eradicating student hunger
we just don't think we need to study it
anymore thank you very much you're
welcome
so with that uh if there's further let's
go ahead we can have also a discussion
when we have the motion on the floor
I'll second that motion we haven't no
that was just a report that came forward
she indicated
she did I did make a motion she did make
a motion okay you were making or you're
not just giving a report
correct first I made the motion then I
reported on it okay okay so thank you
very much representative Tanner second
that motion uh motion made by
representative Mullen
further discussion
I think yes representative Woodcock
thank you under the further discussion I
just want to highlight the fact that it
became very obvious to us that during
the pandemic when there was food being
provided for all youngsters that there
was a better base of nutrition in the
schools and that we now see today with
youngsters back to school that the
significant need to feed all youngsters
that's that's the base for uh their
daily lives and I hope that uh if this
if if re-election works that
representative Ellison and I will bring
back a bill to to supplement that thank
you
see any further discussion
not seeing any further discussion
requests
uh representative Moffett
on HB 1229 recommendation of not rec the
motion is not recommended uh
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
boam yes representative leckis yes
represent moffatt says yes
representative Hobson
yes representative Ford yes
representative Saudi yes representative
Nelson
representative uh Myler yes
representative luno yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison
representative Mullen yes representative
Woodcock yeah representative Heath yes
representative Hall yes 19 to zero
reps lattice also a yes corruption Vlad
makes it 19-0
thank you now a third time's a charm
according to representative Shaw
all right going on to the next bill
which we have HB 1295 requiring reports
concerning school policies on classroom
recordings and in classroom observers I
Look to representative Moffett who had a
subcommittee on this a promotion
uh thank you Mr I motion that we
recommend for future legislation
is there a second
yes oh I'm sorry
the second was from representative he
spoke real quickly here
um representative
recognized for uh discussion on your
motion thank you Mr chair uh yes uh we
had two meetings on this uh on this
measure uh spent quite a lot of time on
it and simply it simply asked that uh
districts
um submit a report of their existing
public policies to Doe
uh with regard to classroom Observer and
recording policies a lot of this is
prompted by a lot of the uh posts or the
covid era uh issues with hybrid classes
remote classes so all it is in the
in the same fashion that we did the
gifted student bill which is now uh uh
no mandate no spending just a request
for a report on public information for
Best Practices so-called folder
discussion
it representative Luna thank you very
much Mr chair
um looking at looking at the history of
house bill
1295. you know I do recall and according
to my notes that that are not to pass
motion actually failed eight to ten in
this in this committee and subsequently
the committee uh voted unanimously to
bring it into interim study
um but but with um with with very little
testimony during its public hearing uh
uh but with uh with maybe a little bit
more testimony during the during the
study committee I think it was pretty
clear that 1295
um
you know creates creates the potential
for uh for some security issues uh for
um for school districts if uh if they're
in fact to um to disclose
um uh uh their um their policies with
respect to um to classroom recordings
and observations so so it it you know I
think I think
it's probably very premature for this
committee to be recommending future
legislation uh given the really the
dearth of um of of formal testimony
during the um during the hearing and um
and I think this is the type of thing
that that the legislature should uh
should most definitely proceed with
caution uh thanks Mr chair yes
uh thank you Mr uh I think I believe
representative luno misspoke uh there
was no OTP motion or vote of eight to
ten it was the motion was to send it to
interim study which it did it went to
interim study we had two sessions and
the subcommittee voted uh four to three
to recommend uh future legislation
um just to rebuttal on that I I
mean we can we can double check this in
the I mean does the clerk have the the
the bill file
uh I don't have that here but I don't
I've got February 24th an OTP motion was
made uh and if and the vote was eight to
ten on that I don't know if anybody else
has notes from the bill and I don't
believe I misspoke you can easily go to
the docket right but and y'all see that
if if this if this is a point of
contention
um then um
yeah actually you're right we can go to
the bill docket
uh yeah yeah thank you representative my
recollection I don't have the notes Here
was that the motion that came out of the
committee was interim study no that was
the motion that came out of the
committee but correct the
but the motion that the the
committee did take
yeah previous motion had failed right
so the bill docket doesn't only reflects
the the past motions that's right okay
thank you but the but the bill file
would would reflect all votes taken
so uh you know in looking at the nature
of what the interim studies bills we
have here obviously they're just going
to go forward and be in in the calendar
we're going to probably see on a number
of these things even no matter how we go
bills are going to come forward
so I don't know if we want to get into a
long discussion on this particular
aspect right now or we want to move on
I'm good yeah just move on okay
so any further discussion so
representative would you please uh call
the roll the motion was again made by
reps and Moffett
and second by
um a second representative cordelli
motion was recommend for further
legislation
representative cordelli yes
representative Phil yes representative
boom yes representative Lucas yes
representative my office is well she is
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodi yes
representative Nelson representative
Myler oh
Representative luno no representative
Cornell representative Tanner no
representative Allison no representative
Mullen no representative woodcock
representative
Heath no representative Hall no
representative Ladd yes makes it 10 to
9. thank you representative Ladd
okay next next uh bill is HB 1313
relative to to rights to freedom from
discrimination in higher education
and I will hand the gavel over to uh
represent cordelli so I can make a
motion please
thank you I will call on representative
Ladd for a motion I would recommend that
this bill will not be moved forward
is there a second
yes second representative Hobson uh
would like the maker like to uh comment
yeah I would
um
I've had since I put this in I've had a
a lot of opportunity to work with uh the
university system in fact I was doing
that on Wednesday Thursday and Friday
this past week at the trustee meeting up
at Plymouth State
um and we we've talked about issues such
as diversity inclusion and Equity
um
providing university-level professors
with the freedom to teach important
ideas and encourage critical thinking
among students is key to Freedom
economic prosperity and innovation
and there are some issues which yes we
have to look at at the University system
of New Hampshire as well as the
community college system New Hampshire
but they're not so much in this domain
as they're in other domains and
administration and how we're handling
some things there so
um I I feel at this point in time that
this bill should not move forward and
that we should respect the academic
freedom that we've provided to our
professors and with the understanding
that as with all issues issues that may
be controversial we want to have open
and open discussion and debate within
the classroom
thank you
further discussion anyone
see none uh I will turn it over to
representative moffatt
thank you representative cordelli on the
mo on HB 1313 the motion to not
recommend made by representative vlad's
second by representative Hobson
uh representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
boom yes representative blackis yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes represent Saudi yes
representative Nelson representative
Myler yes yes representative luno yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yes representative Mullen yes
representative Woodcock yeah yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes representative Ladd yes 1920.
thank you uh moving on down to the sixth
Bill we have here uh 1366. this is
relative to Cooperative School Board
reapportionment as everybody here knows
we had a committee of the whole to look
at three bills that dealt with
Cooperative School District 1366 1399
and 1679 during the discussion it was
very informative uh had some uh good
ideas and and a lot of information out
there we know that there are issues in
the Cooperative school districts
um there are a number of districts which
are having concerns about uh where
they're going and in terms of some are
now trying to find a way out of the
Cooperative school districts no secret
that that's the case we have an active
case right now up in Carroll uh that's
going on we've have others as well where
the tuition rates of uh within that
those cooperatives are very Divergent in
the amount of money which they're
spending in Carol spending what forty
six thousand dollars per pupil per year
whereas others within that particular
District are spending much much much
less down in the 9000 plus dollars
so there is there's uh that issue that
they have and they've gone three times
through the process all the way through
the State Board of Education
appealing the decisions seeing that they
don't have the votes of course to get
out and they're trying to figure out how
they can do that and so they can work
towards trying to find an environment
which is more satisfactory to themselves
up there in Carrollton
that's not unique to the state though so
it's a huge huge issue in terms of
disillusionment into the original
articles or agreement which may have
been made back in the 1960s and since uh
really I haven't changed in accordance
with the demographic within the
community the population student
population or the value of property
within the community in that particular
Cooperative District
uh there's uh a number of those issues
where people are saying well now things
have changed but our agreements we can't
get them changed because we don't have
the votes on the co-op to change them
uh there's so many issues that we felt
that in terms of moving forward that
there is need to study this thing but to
do it in a way that is going to be more
comprehensive than we've done in the
past
um I myself from really
saying here we are kicking the can again
because this is the structured
organization of the state and we're kind
of Trapped into some of this
and we also did that for the purpose of
consolidating districts so we could
eliminate some of the costs of running
these districts that was definitely a a
keen interest of the groups back then
even though I was just a young kid at
the time
so uh I'm
I I you know I I feel that there's uh
a need to study and we are reminded that
we passed legislation last year with any
Commission Now the majority of people on
the commission have to be elected folks
from the senate or the house
so if you have and you can't have a
commission that's any larger than 15
folks
I was reminded of that by Jennifer fore
who brought that to our attention here
about a month ago
so with that said we are looking at a
motion to be made on that and I will
recognize represent cordelli for emotion
and thank you for House Bill 1366 I
would like to move uh not recommended
is there a second
representative Bowman made a second
there so represent cordelli make your
other motion do you have any discussion
on that
uh I think you covered a number of
points thank you
you're welcome
yes
I'd just like to make a point that
um I think that I made when we were
talking about this that we also need to
study the co-ops that are doing well and
to recognize that economy of scale is is
one of the issues with a lot of these
small school districts in in the state
of New Hampshire that's why the co-ops
were put together in the first place and
that perhaps we also include in this
commission a study on what can be done
to help these co-ops come together and
stay together rather than all this
effort and energy being put into
breaking them apart yes that's the
conundrum we have
and we know that there are some that
don't want to disband they're happy the
way they are so that that's the problem
that's the issue representative yeah
Rick thanks I'm um at your request I did
put together some draft language for for
these three bills and the common the
common part
um in in each of them is um is as such
the bill uh the committee recommends
further legislation to establish a
commission to study matters regarding
Cooperative school districts concluding
but not limited to articles of agreement
withdrawal and dissolution joining in
formation funding best practices and
operation and administration and any
other matters related to the governance
of a Cooperative School District
yeah and those are the important topics
of which you know when you disillusion
you're also talking about all those
assets that are within how they divvied
up and that's another tremendous issue
where if there is a commission that
moves forward somewhere along the way
here through future legislation
to ensure that the folks that are on
that commission have a good
understanding of this area of fiscal
management uh would be facilities now
would be very important that folks like
that beyond that particular commission
represent Myler did you also have a
okay
further discussion on the motion
not CNA would you please call the role
representative Moffett
motion if not recommended on HB 1366.
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
Bowman yes representative blackis yes
representative Moffett says yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative Sardi yes
representative Nelson
representative Myler
yes representative luno yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yes yes representative Mullen
yes representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes representative Ladd yes 19 to
zero thank you very much
HB 1373
relative to the best interest of the
student for a change of school or
assignment
uh recognize representative cordelli for
a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move uh not recommended for future
legislation
is there a second
represent boom
makes the second
representative cordelli you recognize
for a discussion uh thank you
um I believe that after submission of
this bill the issue at hand was resolved
uh between the family and the schools so
that the legislation is not needed
Is there further discussion I you were
the sponsor that bill is that correct
that's correct yeah okay
be it known that representative cordelli
is voting against his own bill
okay
any further discussion
represent Moffett
famous sheriff on HB 1373 the motion is
to not recommend
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
bone
representative leckis yes representative
Moffett yes representative Hobson yeah
yes representative Ford
representative Saudi yes yes
representative Nelson
representative Myler yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison representative Mullen yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes representative Ladd yes 19 2-0
thank you uh HB 1399
relative to school district withdrawal
from a Cooperative School District
recognize representative cordelli for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman I would
like to move uh that this be recommended
for future legislation
uh the motion is to move the bill
forward for future
representative seconds
representative cardelli would you please
uh discuss your your motion yes thank
you
um irregardless of a commission that
will take at least a year into the end
of 2024
withdrawal from a Cooperative school
district is I think the Crux of the
matter with Cooperative districts and we
need to
not wait for another year and a half to
go by to have legislation for this this
matter we have had 17 bills on
Cooperative school districts in the past
four years there is clearly a a problem
as was pointed out and I would recommend
future legislation on this withdrawal
matter
may I ask why you you've chose this bill
as to move this one forward
um I I think it was similar in some
regards to 1366 but
um I think that this was uh specific to
withdrawal process I think there might
be some tweaks needed but I think it is
the basis for something
that we can put forward in legislation
next year
further discussion representative Mila
uh thank you Mr chair uh I I will vote
against this
we've already had a conversation about
this earlier this morning
I'm Mr chair you uh outlined the issues
very appropriately
to the breadth of this particular
problem
and to take one bill and isolate it from
a full study
to me would be inappropriate
notwithstanding the problem that is
there with co-ops but in order to solve
the co-op there needs to be a detailed
study around this and this is just an
isolated way to try to deal with it and
I would have encouraged the committee to
vote against this motion thank you
further discussion
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair yeah I agree with what
representative Miler just said I think
um I think taking a position the
committee to take a position that this
bill should uh should move forward
undermines the uh the the the entire
premise behind having a um a
comprehensive commission to study comp
issues comprehensive to um uh to
Cooperative school districts and and
obviously
um withdrawal and dissolution being uh
being one of them but I think
recommending 1399 going forward is uh is
very much akin to uh uh to what another
bill we're going to take up which is
1679 which would actually require all
Cooperative school districts to um uh to
abandon
um so um uh so so
without with without being able to take
into consideration thoughtful
deliberation among a broad base of
stakeholders I think does a disservice
to every Cooperative School District
every family every taxpayer every
student in those districts and I urge
people to vote against the motion thank
you you know representative
thank you Mr chairman
we know
of all the years I've been here there's
going to be a bill next year
God is what we do on withdrawing from a
Cooperative school districts
and so I think this is the one really
need to go forward and really needs to
look at even though we have a commission
we've had those for you know how many
times and this really needs to be looked
at because there are a lot of schools
trying to withdraw and they like you
said before they don't have the votes to
do it so we need to really look at
withdrawing from a co-op thank you
further discussion representative Mullen
um it's a question more than uh more
than a comment um did we know we had a
full committee study session on these
Cooperative bills correct that's correct
and did we not come out of that meeting
saying that we were all in agreement to
a commission that would look at things
comprehensively without separating the
bills into their individual parts and
pieces that's correct so this represents
a change from what we did in that study
committee yeah I think that some of the
change
that's are some of the issues which are
giving folks to really look back at what
we did as a committee of the whole
is that I for one have also been
contacted by a district several
districts which have gone through the
appeal process twice
and still are coming up short
and they're advocating the they're
looking for an experience which is best
for the students in their District
and one of which they can afford
um so I know that we're going to have
these bills coming at us there are
Cooperative bills that are going to come
at us that may perhaps not be already
filed but they they are in the the
process of being drafted uh these
districts are looking for some you know
answers now
um
and so I I myself support the the
commissions uh these studies
recommendation that a commission be
formed I think that's absolutely
imperative however on the other side we
have the the districts which come forth
and they're not a lot there's just less
than a handful but they are needing some
direction right now or some help
so I I myself am not opposed to putting
one of these bills forward I would not
put forward the louder Bill uh 16 19 79
79 that just you know acts the whole
thing uh co-ops would be totally gone
and I think co-ops as represent Tanner
said some are are functioning very well
but others are not and I think as a
legislature
were responsible for trying to listen to
even those which are in the minority on
this right now that are having those
problems so I'm not objecting to
a bill coming forward in the future
which deals with
with the issues that they have and it
may even give more input and support to
a commission study which is imperative
that we do
um school boards associations in support
of a larger study that we've talked
about numerous groups are I I think
that's the way to go but I also am
worried and concerns that maybe were not
able to address where we should be as
representative boam says 17 bills come
in the past
there's been a bill dealing with co-ops
just about every year that I've been in
this house I don't know if we'll ever
get resolution but I don't see any harm
in this topic being discussed and are
looking at it and trying to find
maybe an Open Door somewhere if it's
absolutely necessary or maybe fixing it
so that they don't want the door to open
that they can in fact fix it internally
on the local level
many of them however are just not
successful at the local control issues
so I think there's time for
some help from us
so that's I'm trying to respond to what
you asked yes we did do the committee
Hall but uh so just could I ask you a
follow-up question chairman lad thanks
so the original Bill 1399 went to
interim study because it had ish it had
issues
so if we move forward or if you're
proposing to move forward with uh with
legislation are we saying a new bill is
to be written what happens to the
language of 1399. I'm looking at the
title of that bill which is looking at
primarily at how to withdraw from equal
op I understand for example we had
another bill that was put forth by
representative Litchfield as you recall
in her district there and we have that
that bill didn't go anywhere uh but it's
it's more in the same lines and you know
I I'm not interested in getting down
into the discussion on on do I get one
man one vote type thing from my
districts and then we split the rest up
in accordance that's that's that that
attacks the articles of agreement that
many districts have in place right now
uh some are strictly one man one vote I
believe that that was very close to what
they had up in in in Gorham
in the Shelburne area
however I do believe that by by moving
and saying yes we are open to business
and trying to deal with this topic that
this is the signal that maybe these
districts that have appealed and
appealed
and spent money on it and not come out
successful they have concerns uh I'm I'm
all ears trying to listen to it I'm in a
co-op District where we're very happy of
course there's only one town in it and
they're all seven at large so they would
be uh and that's a set they're all
different
so representative luno so thanks Rick
and I I appreciate that and I appreciate
the fact that that uh there are a
handful of Cooperative school districts
I I and I shouldn't I shouldn't say that
that there are a handful in of towns or
pre-existing school districts within
Cooperative school districts that may um
may may have have certain reasons why
they're looking to uh to exit the um the
co-op but uh again just like what
representative Baume said this is
something that should be looked into
instead what we're recommending is
taking
future action obviously not not with
this bill but but future affirmative
action on policies that would uh would
Define how a um how how a division how
there would be a division of property
and liabilities should a um should a
pre-existing School District you know a
town want to um want to withdraw from a
uh from a co-op and what we're what
we're essentially saying if we're
recommending this for future legislation
uh as opposed to study is um is things
like um uh like Roman 3 online 26 of the
bill a pre-existing School District that
withdraws from or as part of a
dissolution of a Cooperative School
District shall be paid by The
Cooperative School District the
pre-existing School District's
proportional share of net Equity so so
if if if these Cooperative school
districts had recently let's say
um uh uh invested in in um in in school
buildings or other infrastructure it
basically puts the remaining towns in
that District on the hook
to pay back the um the uh the
withdrawing School District I think
these things deserve further study and
uh and and thoughtful study involving
all the all the stakeholders and not
some sort of affirming policy action
from uh from this committee saying oh
yeah this is this is Full Speed Ahead
with uh with this policy because I I
think these these things have uh have
significant consequences to
um to you know not only the withdrawing
District but the remaining
um I mean the withdrawing town but uh
but but especially the towns that remain
within the um the co-op District I I
think it's a very dangerous move
represent cordelli uh thank you
um over the weekend I had a discussion
with one of the principals from Carol uh
New Hampshire and they were
um
they've gone through the process
multiple times very recently up through
a investigation by the State Board of
Education into the whole process that
they went through this last time
they're very distressed to hear that
we're might be doing nothing for another
year and a half two years
um
so I I think that recommending this for
future legislation
um also sends a message to those towns
that do want to get out of their uh
Co-op districts that
um we hear them and we want to help them
and waiting just uh for a year and a
half two years we we want to try and do
something uh in the meantime there are
plenty of things that can be looked at
in addition to the withdrawal process by
uh by a committee but
I feel that you know we need to listen
to those districts that do want to find
a different solution and Carol had
already worked out agreements tuition
agreements with um to provide for all
their students at less than half the
cost of what they are currently paying
in The Cooperative District so it's a
huge issue for them and in other
districts as well and I don't think we
can turn our back on them
yes represent Alexis
some questions
so if we
recommend
yes are we just saying are we saying
this bill the way it was we want to go
forward or just
future legislation regarding how to get
out of a Cooperative School District
as I stated at the beginning when we
talk about the concept of interim study
and the two motions we can make but
there's also those little bullets you
can put underneath trying to orient
where you're going and what you're
recommending for example there may be
under 13.99 a school district that or a
district within the co-op that wants to
get out and we don't want to take any of
the net Equity that that we have in that
other building we don't want you
captured you keep it you don't have to
pay us a thing we just want out
there may be some special circumstances
where that is and that is a an issue
that's happening in one of the districts
we haven't talked about here at the
table today they don't want anything
back from it they just went out
represent boom
thank you and one of one of the problems
we have if you have a very little tiny
small school district that has very few
votes on whether or not anything gets
done and the other two big districts
that this is a co-op with wants to build
this big gigantic new school
the one of the reasons they want to get
out of the school district is they won't
don't want to be able to don't have the
resources to pay for that new big school
so that's one of the problems also and
all of that can be even in this moved
this forward the bills can all be also
be amended to be what we want anyway
like we all we've done so yeah one of
the problems is a lot of these tiny
school districts can no longer afford to
pay for those big schools the biggest
school districts decided to vote on and
that's been an issue over the years
thank you
further disrepresent Tanner
this is a question
um since the committee as the whole when
we got through studying this we came up
with
um a recommendation is that also listed
on uh whatever's going forward that that
this bill was actually part of a
committee of the whole that that the
committee of the whole recommended a
commission and not individual bills so
that
um there's some record of that available
I don't think there's any objection to
that uh it's it's fact it occurred uh
the committee a whole recommended this
however when we're taking action in the
executive session
this is not the direction that we would
be going and there's I think there's
been a rationale or a perspective given
to why that motion would go the other
way
represent Mullen
thank you Mr chair um I'm not sure that
I understand whether or not
representative Leck has got an answer to
her question the question was if you
vote Yes to move forward with
legislation is it this exact bill that
moves forward or is it the concept that
moves forward and what happens to all of
the concerns and and questions that we
had about the original Bill thank you
representative cordelli uh thank you
um I just I have some um
previous
um reports uh from
um committees on interim study bills and
I'm looking at one
um
HB 1652 teacher preparation for
mathematics scholarship program and the
report was authored by Mary Gile
and in her report she said talks about
the intent of this bill to recruit high
school students
she goes on to say however more work is
needed on this bill so I don't think
that
necessarily has to be that bill
um word for word as indicated in this by
uh our former chairman Mary Gile
so representative
Luna yeah thanks very much Mr chair
um just on this on this similar string
that I think representative Lucas
started here
what what what what happens today has no
bearing really on on what gets what's
what gets filed and I think we all you
know recognize that but but the vote
that we take today
um is is
particularly if it's a vote to recommend
it it is a taking a position affirming
material you know Clauses in this uh
material provisions
in this build particularly the one that
that I read off from Roman three with
respect to uh withdrawing uh
pre-existing School District that
withdraws
um uh shall be paid by The Cooperative
school district for its uh Equity so so
you know it's it's basically saying okay
we're affirming that I mean may not be
the exact language or or something like
that throughout it but we're affirming
these these material Provisions in the
bill and and saying that that's okay
um absent having a uh really hearing
from from what about the what about the
remaining School District what about the
remaining towns in that in that school
district that are then going to be on
the hook to then raise their local
budgets to pay off a a town that that
wants to exit what's going to happen to
them what's going to happen to their tax
rates what's going to happen to their
credit worthiness if they're if they're
going to have to bond this and I think
there's a lot of unanswered questions
associated with that obviously you know
a new bill would come forward may or may
not have these Provisions in it it'll go
through a full hearing and and stuff
like that we'll probably get answers to
some of these questions but until we get
answered until we know what where what
what what would happen to these um to
these school districts or to these towns
who would be on the hook
um I I don't know why this committee
would take an affirming position on
these policies well I don't think the
the nature of the title of this bill it
says relative to school district
withdrawal from a Cooperative School
District so you definitely would be
looking at both situations you speak to
how is this going to impact those within
the district how it's going to impact
out
um and and
what may be being proposed in a specific
uh bill that comes forward I would want
to look at the condition and criteria
that there that that Bill's talking
about so I I think what this is
basically saying yes we understand this
is such a deep
subject that we do need further work on
and I hate to say study though we need
some really solid work done on this you
know it hasn't been successful up to
this point other than what we chipped
around the side with Jim grenier's uh
particular group however we do have an
issue out to this nagging at us and I
don't want to slam the door saying we're
not going to talk about this or we're
recommending we not talk about it until
after we have this study there may be
something comes to us that has some
specifics in it and Criterion conditions
which address some of the concerns you
you mentioned representative luno so I'm
open to you know having this this crack
so that we can you know send the message
you know you know that we're we're
involved with both the study and the
we're listening to your needs right now
and perhaps we may be able to help you
representative
just want to make sure I've got this
right because I've heard all these
different opinions on what this means if
we vote Yes all we're doing is saying
yes some legislation should come through
before and I think it's probably going
to be closer to three years because we
already decided that a study that's only
one year isn't long enough because
that's what a commission because the
last one was one year and so we were
talking two years
but then it would be the following
Year's legislation and so this is just
all we're saying is yes in the meantime
we should do
something but not necessarily
this bill is that correct
the concept represent Nelson
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
may seem silly but they live in a small
town and we they want to pull out and
let's say there's 10 million dollars of
debt they owe now
a couple years that they're willing to
sit out pay off their debt and the towns
decide the next year they're going to
build this monstrous
new school are they required to have to
continue paying that or are they
forgiven for the new building that's
part of the question of what you're
dealing with right now in one small
village in this state
and it's on the horizon and they're
looking for some assistance in trying to
better understand what you're saying
it's a real issue
they're basically locked in
right now
the debt that's in you know uh gotten by
that new facility
and see therapy okay thank you
represent woodcock yeah
um I'd like to go back through represent
weeks the question could I must have
missed your response I heard she had a
pretty direct question to you and I
didn't hear the response
the timeline on anything that we put
forward if you if the a bill comes in
you know it's not going to go in effect
until the governor signs it in law if
that in fact even happens that's going
to be next summer
around that area then you put the
commission together and by the
commissions put together you're probably
in the fall
and you're now studying it on the second
year out
um then it's going to be the third year
where you have implementation if that
because there's going to be from the
commission there's going to be statutory
change comes out of that and you're
going to go through the process of
another bill of sorts so it's going to
be a a commission report is going to uh
and and putting it all into works it's
going to be I would say three four years
out in front of us and these districts
some of them can't wait that long that's
why I believe that we should be open to
listening to their proposals listening
to legislation that comes in and
um and try to assist them everywhere we
can
represent Heath I see over there
um thank you Mr chair isn't it possible
though
um in with an urgent situation that the
State Board of Education has some
authority over this
go ahead represent cordelli uh no
um I'd be glad to send you the uh study
that they just did or the investigation
they just did into the withdrawal
process in Carroll
um and their attempt to withdraw from
the White Mountain Regional District
Co-op district and the and the uh
recommendation that they made in that
last sentence it's basically throwing it
back on the co-op you guys work this out
thank you
okay let's go ahead and and take a vote
on this right now uh the motion is on
the table would you please read that
motion uh representative Moffett Amos
you're the
motion is made by representative
cordellian seconded by representative
boom to recommend uh HB 1399 for future
legislation
and we'll run the row yes okay uh
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes
representative bone yes representative
leckis
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodi yes
representative Nelson
representative Myler no Representative
luno no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Ellison representative Mullen no
representative woodcock
representative Heath no representative
Hall no uh and representative Ladd yes
ten to nine
okay we're now at 11 o'clock and as I
mentioned we want to get to that one
bill prior to our
you know leaving today that's 1680 and
I'm going to take a five minute caucus
here to work in and everybody should
take a short caucus here
um and then we'll come back and we'll
look at 1680 next
so we're going in a caucus
[Music]
oh yes
which information
this if this is something that
um that are uh
um
we're ready to go ahead and we're going
to go on 1680 first
and I Look to represent Lakers for a
motion
I move that we not recommend
um 1680.
and represent Hobson second
okay we have motion on the table to not
recommend that uh 1680 move forward
and second by represent Hobson uh
represent Lakers do you have any
arcs any discussion
there are a whole lot of problems with
this so
no that's it
further discussion
yes represent luno thank you very much
Mr chair
um so just for the record
um uh we have filed uh language
identical to 1680 to bring forward in
this coming session I hope voters from
all across the state recognize that that
at least house Democrats are serious
about solving school funding problems um
really important thing to note
about 1680 is that it was a good faith
uh attempt uh working across the aisle
with actually the governor's appointment
to the school funding Commission in uh
in developing all the provisions in um
in 1680. most importantly it uh it
focuses on closing student opportunity
gaps because when you close student
opportunity gaps you're you're doing
right by students you're doing right by
kids you're doing right by families and
taxpayer fairness follows
follows that so um so you know in the
nutshell when um when when when we're
going around knocking doors yeah there's
a lot of issues that I think um that I
think voters from across the state have
on the top of their minds but top
priority of among the top priorities is
property taxes what are you doing about
my property taxes what are you doing
about school funding voters get it and
um and Democrats get it and uh and
that's something that we'll be bringing
forward
um you know a major part of uh 1680 is
also a meaningful property tax relief
plan
so so uh you know not only does uh does
does 1680
um uh improve opportunities for students
but it establishes a um a fair uh uh
property tax rate that in any town
across the state wouldn't have to exceed
five dollars per thousand so um so um
you know if this committee wants to take
a a partisan position against 1680 then
uh then I hope uh I hope voters all
across the state uh recognize that
further discussion
represent Miler uh thank you Mr chair uh
this uh recommendation by the Republican
caucus is indeed disappointing
I shared with the with those of us that
were here that were studying this
an article
that was printed in 1984.
that compared the disparity between the
Hopkinton school district and the
Pittsfield school district
that disparity has increased in the last
40 years not decreased
we had a uh we had a commission to study
school funding
that commission for the first time in 40
years
had an outside group that came in and
looked at our data from school districts
that basically said that the disparity
within the school districts is
increasing not to decreasing
we came up with a formula for the first
time
that provided a reallocation of current
school funding not an increase in taxes
but taking the current school funding
that provided a different way of
allocating those resources to those
schools that are in need
we talk about student Equity we talk
about equal educational opportunities
this bill provides that
we have more data now than we've ever
had before when the original input model
was created that basically said in the
input model here's a same amount of
money for every student regardless of
what the need is
what we're proposing here is a different
way of funding schools that provides
equity for kids
very disappointed we had hoped uh that
we could have some bipartisan support on
this
because of the need across the state
and this is very disappointing from a
standpoint of not recognizing the true
nature of the of the uh the disparity
that's there
the inequitable opportunity for students
across the state and um we will be
visiting this again next uh next session
Big Time thank you Mr chair thank you
very much representative
Lucas
just very briefly I want to say that
putting more money to change outcomes
has been tried for decades and there is
no correlation between money in and
results out and so that is one of the
top issues here and yes we need to
figure out something but this is not it
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair we just got through
discussing
um The Cooperative breakups and how
there's a handful of schools
that were sending a message that were
giving them hope
and I'm just looking at the the lawsuits
that we've had for over well a couple of
decades anyway about school funding and
I'm looking at
Newport a town that I represent right
now Claremont Town nearby and I'm
looking at the taxpayers in those towns
and the students in those towns who are
suffering and that they're not the only
ones we know that there are many schools
across the state we know this is a big
issue and we are sending a message that
we don't really
think it's a big deal and I think that
has to be
um put in in context of what we did with
the Cooperative bill that that um we
recommended that I think we should
recommend this bill to give hope to
those schools and those kids
and those taxpayers that are suffering
under the current school funding process
thank you thank you I'm going to take
one more
any further discussion
represent woodcock
thank you chairman
um
I'm amazed that a bill of this magnitude
that had commissioned study was
presented
with like a five-word
answer is too much to take care of
um and
I would question the data that the
representative is using when she said
there's no correlation between money in
and outcome
you look at the amount of resources that
are putting it put into different school
systems and you look at the outcome
there's clearly a connection and a
correlation between resources presented
for children in schools then there isn't
you look at any of the data that talks
about the the income level and the
amount put forward by schools for
students and the servers they can
provide
if you have a team that has one
basketball
and you have a team that has 20
basketballs and 20 kids who do you think
have a better opportunity to practice
there's no different resources put in
here and I'm sure representative Moffett
remember that because it comes right
along that same line uh is where are we
going when we don't give equal resources
that's what this is this is an Eco
resource bill I was so happy to see that
finally something came that I was
mistaken when I read the commission
report and then read the pamphlet that
came on the commission report and then
listen to the data from the dialogue of
the year that all of a sudden now note
this is it we're not going to go forward
we're going to go back to what we said
was really important we need to be able
to find a desk in a chair that's really
important we only have those that's how
we're going to figure out how we're
going to progress with school systems uh
no forget about outcomes forget about
achievement figure out what resources in
so saying that that resources did not
support success is really not clear and
it is a host of data between even things
as simple as family income and resources
and Student Success as the same with
schools
when you look across that the calendar
of every single town and the cost that
puts in purest child for the per diem
cost clearly is a connection between a
town that invests 42 thousand dollars in
a town invests nine thousand dollars a
resources for those kids so it clearly
is a lot
thank you representative Moffett would
you please call the roll
maybe share on the motion to not
recommend on HB 1680 uh representative
cordelli yes yes
representative Hill yes Rosenbaum yes
representative legis yes represent
Moffett yes representative Hobson yes
representative Ford yes represent sodi
yes representative Nelson representative
miler
no
Representative luno no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Ellison representative
Mullen no representative woodcock
you know
representative Heath no representative
Hall no representative Ladd yes
10 to 9.
okay the next bill which we have
is 1676
oh wait a minute yes 1676 relative to
making incentive grants for school
districts
that improve in certain assessment
scores
uh representative Moffat do you have a
motion
uh yes Mr I move that we uh recommend
for further legislation
is there a second
we have a motion made by representative
moffatt second by represent Hobson uh to
move uh this legislation forward uh
representative uh Moffat you're
recognized hey Michelle briefly uh we
had a subcommittee we met twice on this
uh talked about in great detail
um and uh voted four to three to
recommend
future legislation
further discussion
represent
Allison
I was on that subcommittee I'm one of
the three votes that against moving this
forward uh we've gone over and over and
over
this issue uh in particular one of the
things that stands out in particular is
it's it's a program that would reward I
guess school districts a little unclear
in the bill about how we would determine
which school districts would be
available for incentive grants but the
basis here is we're going to give could
give more money to those districts that
are doing very well and we would not be
giving money to those districts that are
in need of of resources uh
I I and as I said in the subcommittee uh
I I'm done voting for bills to give
money to school districts that don't
need it or have a lot of money already
uh I will only vote for Bill funding
bills that will push money to the school
districts that are in need of services
for their students uh
following note with with representative
Moffett I mean this goes against his
philosophy of sports which is that those
who
in the National Basketball Association
the National Football League the teams
that do worse get additional draft
choices and they're the first ones to go
so the the issue there is that's where
the resources should go they don't give
additional draft choices to the Golden
State Warriors because they won the uh
NBA championship last year uh and I've
made that point before so I I'm very
clear on this one uh very disappointed
if we move forward in a direction that
is going to uh reward school districts
who are doing well and uncertainly I I
represent uh two districts two school
districts in my district that do well
particularly well uh and might well be
candidates for an incentive Grant but
it's very unclear about what this thing
looks like what it should do uh and I'm
certainly not going to vote for moving
this bill forward thank you
representative Moffett they must share
very briefly uh what we as I understand
the process we don't want to get really
prescriptive Here and Now on the exact
implementation of uh the the incentive
Grant Bill the what we're talking about
is I see it is per earlier conversations
today is the notion the concept of
rewarding achievement and I'll go back
very briefly to the fact that we give
money to third grade this goes with
deficient third grade scores in in
essence uh rewarding failure frankly so
uh the the details the prescriptive
details will will be worked out in
whatever comes forward uh ahead of us
and I will tell you also that uh in
subsequent discussion there's been a
some discussion about focusing strictly
on math
so something that comes forward in the
coming term depending upon who's in the
mix uh the person the details will be
worked on but I I and many others
parents you know we want we keep hearing
about trying to get more money more
funding for Education here's some more
funding for Education that's going to
reward uh Innovation or successful
Innovation results in achievement so
thank you
okay uh call call the role please
representative
okay well I didn't see any hands up
representative Tanner my hand up
um thank you
um I I take umbrage at the
um rewarding failure by giving money uh
particularly for the third grade reading
program
um I think what it does is it identifies
schools that have a particular need uh
more need than others uh for
more
resources for reading and I think this
this is just the
um whole Aura of this bill that we we
um say to the schools that are having
issues and we know that they are and I
talked about how you know we're trying
to give hope to these schools hope that
there that somehow they the funding is
going to change the resourcing is going
to change and that they will have some
some hope that they can move on with
their and improve student outcomes
um and we know that it's a resource
issue we we know that tremendously so
um this the people that work at these
schools the students that are at these
schools that are in representative
moffett's term failures and are getting
rewarded are working very very hard
they're working very hard and the
schools that are doing very well as as
represent Ellison said and I represent
some of those
get their own rewards they get extra
grants they get extra commendations uh
they get teachers that are moving from
from lower functioning schools because
they have higher salaries they have
a whole lot of benefits already so I
just this is a slap in the face really
to those schools that are struggling
financially I think
representative whitcock
thank you um
this this
is
I can't think of any more inappropriate
than
seeing a need and saying we're not going
to give it to you we're going to give to
someone already is doing well
when we have classes that are that are
at the lower level or the lower quartile
and they're working to move up
we're gonna move up and you say no we're
not going to help you we know you're at
the bottom and you're you know you don't
have everything you need but we're not
going to help you we're going to give it
to the class that's doing really well
let's give it the school is doing really
well and give them more money on top of
you down there just sort of suck it up
and keep on going
um I think that makes absolutely no
educational sense at all if you said to
the school it was down on the the bottom
you know what you made great gains from
last year this year you might get
something well that makes sense thank
you so much for more resources but not
to say Oh no you're up top now we're
gonna keep you there so if you're down
the bottom now we're going to keep you
there too and we're going to do with
taxes it just makes no sense to me to
give incentive dollars and I don't care
if it's reading scores math scores or
anything and sent the money to school
that is successful
incentive when you threw an innovation
that's a whole different ballpark but
what you said bill is incentive so I I I
I have a total um uh concern that the
philosophy behind finding this is is uh
poorly orchestrated
uh thank you Mr briefly what I'm hearing
are a number of assumptions on how this
is going to be implemented the the
formula for implementation is TBD to be
determined so these assumptions about
that I'm hearing um are premature I
think thank you okay I'm going to uh
call this motion right now
um representative moffatt would you
please uh call the roll famous here on
the motion to recommend on HB
1676 uh representative cordelli yes
representative Hill
representative Baum yes representative
leckis yes representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes
representative Sardi yes representative
Nelson
representative Miler no Representative
luno no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Ellison
representative Mullen no representative
woodcock
representative Heath no representative
Hall no representative Ladd yes
ten to nine
okay the next
what's that
1664.
uh requiring certain non-public schools
or education service providers that
accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers
representative cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman my motion is to recommend
excuse me to not recommend this for
future legislation is there a second
represent Lucas so we have a motion on
the table to not recommend 1664 to go
forward made by cordelli second by
lekkas representative cordelli nothing
further
further discussion
represent Tanner
thank you
um been working on the background checks
for a long time and I really feel that
we need to have
background checks for all people who are
particularly
um you know what we control which is
with taxpayer-funded money people that
receive that under the guise of
Education one way or the other
um all get the same background checks as
certified teachers do in public schools
and those background checks are not just
employee background checks but there are
specific checks to to
provide a safety
net around students from potential
Predators potentials sexual offenders
and by killing this bill not
recommending it we have once again
allowed these students to be
vulnerable
um and I just I I
find it hard to believe that we can't
come to an agreement about background
checks we do it for Camp counselors we
do it in the health care field we do it
for certified teachers we do it for bus
drivers we do it for staff in public
schools and if we're
spending money to send kids
children out to other educational
opportunities then those people that are
dealing with those kids
in an in a situation where they're alone
with them for any extended period of
time rather than volunteering like we've
we've know that it's already in statute
and not do background checks I just I it
it's just unbelievable to me that that
we aren't supporting that thank you
representative cordelli uh thank you uh
it's already being done law is not
necessary
thank you Mr chair it is our
responsibility to make sure our children
in the state of New Hampshire are as
safe as possible and if we can take this
one simple step to move forward to
protect our children it's something we
should do we have seen incident after
incident after incident of children in
our non-public schools being perpetrated
by someone who has a record and if they
had had a background check that would
have been picked up on and I'm sorry I'm
not on education anymore but as a former
educator I find it very disheartening
that this body would reject this kind of
a concept
thank you
with that I'm going to I have a question
that's the last question go ahead I've
got a clarification question uh
representative cordelli said it's
already been done in law we've got our
attorney from the Department of
Education right there I'd like to have
her clarify if in fact he's correct
excuse me I didn't say it was being done
in law I said it was being done
well it's an implication I would assume
you're saying that it's being done
you're implemented there are things
there are things that are done in this
state that are not in law
well this would this would this
particular bill would make sure that
it's done because it would then be in
law that it would be done okay thank you
very much on that with that we're going
to call the role representative Moffett
my name is here on the
possible to get the clarification that
representative asked for no
no
he just indicated it had nothing to do
with statutory law that it's in practice
being done
100 that the bill is that I'm I'm not
going to go and answer that question but
uh I am going to call the roll
a motion to not recommend HB 1664
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
Baum
representative blackis yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodi yes
representative Nelson
representative Myler absolutely no
representative luno
no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner
absolutely not representative Ellison
representative Mullen no
representative woodcock
representative Heath absolutely not
representative Hall the big no
representative Ladd yes
ten to nine not recommended
thank you
the next bill which we have here
does anybody have to take a break here
to wash them or anything like that
okay the next bill we have then is
requiring high school students complete
a happier required course in the
introduction to philosophy represent
Hobson
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion that we not recommend 16 30 for
future legislation is there a second
second representative boom
represent Hobson has made a motion not
to request future legislation on 1630
second by representative Bowen represent
Hobson you recommend are recognized
for discussion uh just that uh it's not
the within the purview of this committee
to instruct on curriculum
okay further discussion represent boom
do you have anything yeah just that in
the past of all the years I've been here
we've been having
stuff to add courses to add courses and
it's not really our purview to do that I
remember a lot of time last unless I had
financial aid whatnot we should do it
General on what to do but not a specific
that is not our purview thank you
representative
any further discussion
okay representative moffatt would you
please call the roll on that
on the motion to not recommend HB 1630
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill
yes representative yes representative
blackis yes representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes
Representative sodi no
representative Nelson is not here
representative Myler yes
representative luno yes representative
Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yeah representative Mullen yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes representative Ladd yes
17 to 1.
okay
the next bill
HP 1679
relative to the dissolution and repeal
of Cooperative school districts
representative cordelli thank you I
would move not recommended for future
legislation
is there a second second
represent Hobson makes the second
represent cordelli you're recognized for
discussion
um I I brought this um
Bill forward because I
uh heard what was going on around the
state
um in different districts
um I thought it was
necessary to help force the issue and
not just keep
um having
bill after Bill year after year
um
I think that there are approaches that
can be taken
um in in a bill or dissolution but
I recommend 1679 not go forward
further discussion
yes
did somebody have a yeah it's
representative Woodcock oh
representative I just want to be clear
this this I don't want to screw this up
this is the bill that representative
cordelli brought in that we're going to
shut down all all uh schools and by next
July that we're
um could I answer that
Co-op is that the same boat seeing
representative cardelli was the maker of
it representative cordelli uh this bill
would um require dissolution by July of
2025.25 okay it's not shutting down all
schools um believe me just
it was 2025 that all Co-op schools would
be oh okay I wasn't sure I want to make
sure that the structure would be gone
yeah thank you
schools would still remain open
I guess
um further discussion
representative moffatt
you're called on the not not recommended
motion for HB 1679 representative
cordelli yes representative Hill yes
representative bum yes representative
lekkas yes representative moffatt yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodi yes
representative Myler yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Ellison yeah representative Mullen yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes Interruption of lad yes
18 to zero
okay the next bill which we have is
14.99
relative to Charter Public School
eligibility for state school building
eight I'm going to give the gavel to
representative cordelli uh thank you and
I uh call on representative Vlad for a
motion I recommend that this bill not
move forward
is there a second
uh represented the boom uh further
discussion um representative Ladd the
issue of school building Aid is a
another issue which uh probably most
likely needs the attention of of us in
terms of school building aid for all
public schools
however in this particular situation I
am concerned regarding uh allocating
School building Aid to in the amount of
30 to 60 percent based upon I don't know
what
um uh to a Charter Public School which
does not have the
um
ability that a rigor school district has
to set you know the property tax and and
collect revenues and and and not knowing
what the the charter schools uh ability
to pay for and continue in business
there's a whole lot of issues a state
board can and close them down quickly
the other point of uh that uh regarding
the Charter Public Schools is that
um the
um I'm losing my trend of thought here a
little bit and growing so fast here they
can't the generating the leasing of
schools is a concern
um and uh so with that there's so many
issues associated with this it needs
some resolution and we have asked the
department to look at this and to look
at all School building Aid including the
school building authority which
represent a hill here chairs for the
state how that interacts with the whole
process so this must be done there for
adding and going in another Direction
we've got to make sure what we're doing
is correct we're certainly on the funded
in school building Aid when we see
applications in nature of 600 760
million dollars waiting out there of
which approximately 40 percent of that
or somewhere around 260 something
million dollars in applications that
we'd be obligated to as a state are
looking at and we're funding not even 50
million dollars a year right now with uh
our debt being paid off from that up to
50 million dollars that's approximately
it's about 25 million dollars each year
for the upcoming biennium at least fifty
dollars for 50 million for the biennium
for new construction and new renovation
done income close to touching what we
need so there there are significant
issues out there I recommend this not
move forward
further discussion
I've seen none
representative Moffett
and the not recommended motion for HB
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
Bowman yes representative leicus yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodium yes
representative Nelson is not here
representative Miler yes representative
luno yes representative Cornell
representative Tanner
yes representative Ellison
representative Mullen yes representative
Woodcock yeah representative Heath yes
representative Hall yes representative
Ladd yes
18-0
okay
one more
um HB 234 this is a holdover from the
first year of the of the session we just
finished
uh this is a bill relative freedom of
speech in association on college
campuses
representative uh
Moffett you look
hey Mr I like to make a motion that we
not recommend this measure
is there a second representative Hops
and seconds that motion so motion made
not to recommend that uh HB 234 move
forward made by representative uh
Moffett second by representative Hobson
uh discussion from the maker of the
motion
famous you briefly uh this I actually
chaired in two different terms two
different interim studies on this
on this issue and this measure uh what
we discovered
was that there have been improvements in
the policies on campuses uh Kane for
example had earlier had a red
designation from fire f-ire about a
freedom of speech on campus and they
improved to operating with green UNH was
yellow and is now green
so we did not see the necessity for
statute now that the campuses
are have put in place satisfactory
policies for freedom of speech on campus
further discussion
looks good okay all uh representative
Moffett would you please call the roll
the motion to not recommend on HB 234
representative cordelli yes
representative Hill yes representative
bone yes representative leckis yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
Ford yes representative sodi yes
representative Myler yes
representative luno yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Mullen yes representative
Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
Hall yes and representative Ladd yes
18-0
so this concludes the 15 bills for today
um
is there any other items to come before
the education committee at this time if
not I want to thank all the members who
have participated in the education
committee it's not been a
an easier in many regards with 139 bills
that came at us and
um and even today it's there there are
areas which
um there is agreement a majority of
areas which are the agreement but there
are areas where we have not been able to
agree
and um hopefully we can work towards
some
some resolve on these issues on the
Cooperative School of this uh bills on
the school funding measures which uh we
all know that the does need some work
I'm just concerned that bill we had
forward does not uh do that totally the
way we'd like to see so with that uh any
further discussion or last words I want
to thank representative Heath for coming
in today I've enjoyed working with you
on so many and you've been on this
education committee for years and years
and years and for your work as Deputy
Commissioner over that Doe that's all
appreciated thank you and representative
Nelson's gone we want to thank him too
and representative Mullen and thank you
for your hard work on this committee and
all of you I appreciate that and I ask
that you all drive safely and and have a
good afternoon
thank you